I want to call Brad Williams because he remembered that, you know,
this quading bales thing that happened. I do, yeah. The young gunner,
this Australian young buck and, uh, and people were really lightened into him.
Yeah. Right.
And Brad did a fundraiser for him and it was supposed to be to raise 10 grand.
And I think they raised about a lot more.
I want to say a couple of hundred thousand, unfortunately. Hold on. Okay. Sorry.
Don't hold on. You say whatever you want.
I was going to say, I'm sorry. Pictures.
Pictures of that kid came out with him with strippers and stuff like that.
Did they really? So I don't think he's eight year.
I don't th they say he's not eight or nine years old, but I don't care.
He's still small enough. He still can't get on all the rides.
So we should still just send them out there.
Well, I mean, if you want, I don't know what happened. So what I'm wondering is,
do we know what happened?
And you guys are gonna have to put on the headphones to hear Brad.
And when we call them, I mean, $300,000 is a lot of money.
I don't know Brad's number. All right.
Cause this thing really captivated the nation last week and put the phone in the
middle of the table. Hey brother. What's up man? It's Theo. Hey buddy.
How are you doing? Fantastic. Hey man. Thanks for answering the call. Um, uh,
we got Krista Stefano here, um, in the podcast right now and.
Hey buddy. Hey, uh, Chris, I'm seeing you on Thursday. Okay.
Yes. On Thursday, man. We're going to do Kimball together. Oh,
y'all are little standup. Yeah. We'll you. We showed, we could do that.
I'm down to do that.
Yeah. We're we're yeah. We're going to do a, uh, Jeff Dunham Mac. Yeah.
Hold on.
But bread only of Chris sits on your lap.
Yeah, we're doing a reverse Jeff Dunham.
And it's going to be great. Well, that's your hand up my. So I don't.
Have favorite sex news. Reverse. You have done it.
Yeah, you can do, you can get a re a reverse Jeff Dunham at the,
uh, at the, uh, cat house in Vegas.
Let's do it. Do it. That's why I'll stay an extra night.
Then you don't need an extra night, bro. You just stop by during the day.
All right, I'll do that. I'll be that creeper that hangs out and Brad daylight,
cat house.
You're going to be living in the apartments. Oh God.
Brad. We had, uh,
we talked about the queen bales thing on podcast last week and um,
and everybody's been talking about it.
I know that you did a fundraiser for them. Um,
can you kind of take us through a little bit of that and where you're at now
with it? Yeah.
No problem. Uh, first of all, uh, first of all, he's nine years old,
everybody. Okay. So stop with your conspiracy theories. Uh,
he's nine years old. Anyway. Uh, I got, uh, I got winded the video because,
uh,
I've got some Australian fans that kept sending me the video and I don't
know why they kept sending it to me. Just like, Hey, you're a dwarf,
he's a dwarf. You can help him. Like I like, I don't know.
I don't know what they were thinking like, Oh yeah,
like I've got some hotline or something.
But yeah, but.
I saw it, but I saw the video and like anyone who saw the videos got a pulse,
I was, uh, really moved by it. Uh, of course,
of course I'm a fellow, a little person.
He's got the same kind of dwarfism that I do and I was bullied growing up.
So it really, it, it really spoke to me.
So I thought I got to do something, but I can't, you know, I'm, uh,
I'm out in Los Angeles. What can I do? He's in Australia. So I thought, well,
I'll throw together a go fund me page and send the kid to Disneyland.
I grew up going to Disneyland kids loved Disneyland. So, uh,
I did that set the goal at $10,000 because with $10,000 you can buy him
flights tickets and maybe two churros. Uh, those things are expensive.
Um, and I figured, you know, that that'd be, that'd be a good time.
So instead of the $10,000 tweeted it out and then I went to bed
and uh, the next day it was an $18,000.
And then a huge Jackman talked about it. William Shatner talked about it.
It started getting passed around all these celebrities. Uh,
and then currently we're at $460,000.
Yes, ma'am for a weekend.
Oh, the boy is going to buy Disneyland. And I'm thrilled about that.
I hope it's worth owns Disneyland.
Cause then probably no more height requirement.
Okay. That'd be great. Yeah. Pretty smelling the whole day.
So whenever the, whenever the, the, the conspiracy theories came out, I mean,
just because, you know, people are skeptical over everything. Um,
what did you do then?
Oh man, I just kinda let it go.
Like if I chase down every person that
was talking about it or saying that he's 18 years old or that he's,
he's not really 18, he's a 45 year old actor, you know,
just weird stuff like that.
He was in Dunkirk. That's what people were saying.
What were they dropping them out of? The plane, all kinds of stuff.
I have no idea.
He played one of the bombs dropping them onto the Germans. Yeah.
People were there.
Kinds of conspiracy theories. People were saying that he worked for the city.
I remember somewhere outside of Akron, there was all kinds of wild stuff.
But did you, did you check with him,
did you do any other recon to make sure that you were like,
did you have any question?
Yeah. I mean, I just wanted to make sure that, uh, he's a good kid and that,
you know, he's a kid, but I got the FaceTime with them and, uh,
FaceTime with both him and his mom.
And that's back when the fundraiser was at $20,000 and it really hadn't
picked up yet, uh, new, uh, news organizations.
Weren't really talking about it. Uh, so I was FaceTiming with him.
He seems like a fun normal kid.
And then once it started going above like $50,000,
$75,000, uh,
I started reaching out to a bunch of different people that, um,
run charities and do these kinds of things, all things all the time. Uh,
GoFund me is an incredible website. Uh,
because once a fundraiser hits a certain point,
they assign a team to that fundraiser.
So I had a team from go-fund me and constant, constant communication,
and they vetted everything. They, they looked into everything,
they did amazing work, so yeah. Where does the money go?
Well, and, uh, we, we posted an update on the page. Uh,
so Caden and his family actually released a statement that said that
they are turning down the trip Disneyland and they want all the money to just go
to charity. Wow. So he's, he's ridiculous.
The charity is he picked a charity. How does it work? Uh,
I did another FaceTime call with him and, and his mom.
And we kind of went through all, all the charities that we wanted to go through.
Because if you look at the original wording on my GoFundMe,
I said any excess money would be donated to charity. Uh,
so we, we picked some great charities and, uh,
they're actually posted right now on the GoFundMe page. We picked, uh,
six different charities. Uh, some, some charities,
yeah, stomp out bullying, uh, born this way.
Those are two charities in the United States. There's four charities in,
in, in Australia,
we're giving about $66,000 to each of those charities.
And then whatever money is left over, uh, I,
I decided to give it to Katie and his family and said, uh,
you guys can spend that money, however you want.
I know you're turning down money,
but many people donated to this fund with the thought of their money going
directly to the family. Right. So I thought on.
Is it 400,000 us or Australia?
Yeah. It's a 460,000 us over
700,000 Australian.
They could buy one of those, they could buy the Aborigine people.
Well, not all of them. You could buy probably a couple.
Uh, and, uh, this is a good time to add that, uh,
some of the charities are anti-black racism charities that stand up for the
rights of the Aborigine people. Absolutely.
I haven't met an Aborigine person. Have you? I would love to. I would,
I would love to meet one I'd know. Cause I have a,
I don't think I have any Aboriginal, uh, fans, but I'm looking for that.
That's one of the things I'm trying to get from my podcast.
There you go. You got to get some.
And I, Brad too, because, you know, cause I'm only,
I'm just a victim of the internet as well. There it's like,
all these pictures are like, Oh, he's 19 years old. He's with strippers,
he's got guns. I mean, how do they do all that? Like what, like.
What is it? What is a Photoshop?
The internet is an amazing place. Uh, both good and bad.
I mean, there were, there were people that were spreading rumors that like, Oh,
uh, like there was some,
like I looked at a lot of this stuff because I wanted to make sure that the,
that, that the money was going to a good spot.
There was one person who had a Facebook talk show that said,
like that Kayden was like this nine year old running around, uh,
the school, like sexually assaulting girls. And I mean, they,
they, they said that their proof was that they read one Facebook comment that,
and they posted the Facebook comment and it said, Oh, a friend of mine, his,
his kid goes to the same school and noticed some girls where this
happened. I'm like, really? You're going through all this off of Facebook. Like,
yeah. Do you.
Is there, I mean, yeah, there's all kinds of stuff. Somebody,
people who said he opened up for Gucci mane, there was all kinds of.
Well, that,
that is the problem is when UTA signs him and he starts taking dates away from
everybody, we'll be like, you, Brad. That's a great point, man. You know,
they signed bagel boy bagel.
Oh yeah. They had this kid named lightening rod, a lightning rod.
I don't want to say lightening rod lightening, Rodney.
Maybe when I was growing up,
some guy that got hit by lightning and they tried to turn them around locally.
Really? He was probably moving major tickets.
He wasn't doing anything. Maybe 40 tickets sell out. Now what about this bread?
Are there higher costs associated with being like a, a little person growing up?
Like, are there costs that, are there extra costs?
Yeah. Well, like just in terms of, I mean, at your most basic costs, uh,
most clothes that, uh, I would like to buy, uh,
don't fit me. So you got to get stuff that, uh, tailored,
unless you just want to be walking around with like a shirt that has Bob the
builder on it. But, uh, I doubt you want that. So yeah.
You have extra tailoring and then plus a lot of little people have,
uh, medical problems, whether it be neck or, uh, leg surgeries,
I've had one dwarf related surgery on my legs. So yeah, they,
they can, they, they can get problems that way as well.
So that's why I wanted to give the family a little bit of money just because
if those kinds of things are coming up with Caden,
I want to make sure that they're taken care of.
And that's what the people who gave money to the campaign wanted as well. So,
uh, that's dope. Yeah. And, and, and, and it's really great. And really,
and, and people stepped up and we ended up donating a ton of money to charity.
That's going to anti-bullying and anti-abuse, uh, anti-racism charities.
So a lot of people are,
a lot of people are going to be helped in a very positive way because of this.
I cannot be more thankful.
Man. And I know, you know, and cause you're, I'm a, I'm a dad.
I know you're a new dad. Congrats. It's like, when I say stuff like that,
and I'm sure it's the same with you. It's like, you can't help. But think like,
what if that was my child being abused that way? Like, you know,
so it's great that you can,
that you made an effort and did it cause I there's things there's times when I
see videos like that. And I'm like, I can't, what if that was my daughter?
And then I have a chance to donate and I just watched porn hub or do something
different, but you actually went out there and made a difference,
which is why you're happily married and, um, you know,
single living with Don to pet on his couch.
There's still time.
Yeah. That's why I got visitation rights, but you, you know,
but you have a full, happy family. There's still time. Uh,
thanks so much, man. And uh, yeah,
at least Chris will be warmed up for your podcast later this week.
Hey, sounds great. Thank you guys, gang gang.
Uh, before he hangs up, can you hear me? Yeah. What's the quickest way to, uh,
get to your GoFundMe. Cause when you just search on go fund me,
we can't find it. So how can we get to the actual GoFund me?
Uh, if you guys still want to donate to the go-fund me, cause it is still open.
Uh, you can, uh,
probably quickest way is just to go to my Twitter and then scroll down the
tweets and you'll find, you'll find links.
I'm on Twitter at funny Brad and uh, if not,
I'm sure you can just Google, uh, GoFund me for,
uh, bullied Australian boy. And something's gonna pop up.
There'll be news articles. There'll be links. Uh, you can.
And there'll be $460,000 in there already. So.
Yeah. Oh man. I had, so, and I had so many friends that were like,
it really makes you realize who your friends are because I had so many friends
that were like, uh, sending you messages, like dude, embezzle it,
take it, go to Sweden. And I was like, yeah.
Oh. What if you disguise yourself as quading and went.
To Disneyland?
Uh, Shay get shave, get a tan. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. It could happen.
Dude. Dude. Thanks so much. It's such a, it's such a cool story to hear, man.
And um, yeah, just thanks for jumping on the line with us and sharing that.
No problem. Love you guys. Love the podcast. See on Thursday, Chrissy.
Thank you. Ma'am good evening. Good afternoon. And other times.
Thanks for watching that video. You just saw. I mean it was okay,
but the next video you could watch could be way better.
What if you watch a video right now that changes your life where you could watch
this one or watch this one, watch this one, watch this one, watch this one.
Ah,